gipfelgespräch zweiter Teil schön dass
sie wieder dabei sind der Gipfel ist zu
Ende deswegen sind wir hier ein bisschen
haben uns zurückgezogen wo wir nachher
die ganzen Stücke schneiden daraus haben
wir ein kleines Studio gemacht und jetzt
beginnen wir mit der Einzelkritik die
ganz wichtig ist fangen wir mit dir an
du hast lange in Indien und über Indien
berichtet Mudi ist das jetzt der neue
Superstar auf der Weltbühne ja er fühlt
sich ganz sicher so die Inder sind viele
Inder sehen ihn ganz sicher so man muss
ja auch fairerweise zugeben das ist ein
großer Erfolg wenn er hier zu verbuchen
hat er hat 20 Stimmen gesammelt also
Einstimmigkeit letzten Endes bei der
gipfelerklärung und das hat vorher nicht
jeder glaubt Stichwort Erfolg Stichwort
Superstar er ist ein bisschen älter Joe
Biden sieht sich natürlich als Superstar
wie ist es gelaufen für ihn ich glaube
der freut sich gerade wie Bolle weil das
war sehr vor drei Jahren versprochen hat
nämlich Amerikas zurück und man muss
Butter bei die Fische tun also den
Worten auch Taten folgen lassen das
scheint sich Stichwort Eisenbahnprojekt
scheint sich abzuzeichnen und das zweite
ist er freut sich auch dass er wo die so
ich sag mal striegeln betütern konnte
weil er damit natürlich ein Signal nach
Peking sendet dass da ein anderer
globalerie ist und man den Ping nicht
unbedingt immer als allerersten sehen
muss
an die berichtet aus dem
Hauptstadtstudio und Scholz ist ja nicht
unbedingt immer der auffälligste bei
solchen Gipfeln aber diesmal mit der
Augenklappe war er irgendwie der
optische Star wie ist es für ihn
gelaufen wenn man es misst an den
Erwartungen wie sollst tut dann war es
in Erfolg wenn man es misst am Ergebnis
wie ist der Rest der Welt tut dann war
es eine Enttäuschung also die G20 haben
es nicht wiederholt was sie in Bali
gemacht haben Russland klar verurteilt
und das der Mann mit der Augenklappe das
Scholz das als Erfolg verbucht kennen
wir von ihm auch immer die Augenklappe
noch nicht so sehr erkennen geh mal ein
bisschen jetzt ins Detail du hast gesagt
das ist ein großer Erfolg für Mutti weil
er 20 Stimmen gesammelt hat worin
besteht der Erfolg was war die Gefahr
Aussicht dahinter und worin ist jetzt
das was ihn gelungen ist zu scheitern
wäre das Schlimmste gewesen die sind mit
der klaren Vorgabe in den Gipfel
gegangen wir wollen das alle
unterschreiben am Ende nicht nur 18 und
zwei sich vielleicht irgendwie rauscheln
Russland China hätten das sein können
oder das ist Formulierungen gibt die das
alles wieder abschwächen die man so aus
Bali kannte dass die meisten zustimmen
oder das im Grunde alle zustimmen sie
wollten eine klare Formulierung haben
das haben sie geschafft natürlich ist
das Diplomatie das ist auch irgendwie
wie ein Spiel das heißt da wird am Text
dann so gefeilt dass eben 20 den tragen
können natürlich muss man ihn dafür
entschärfen aber für Modi war wichtig zu
zeigen ich kann das schaffen ich kann
die zusammenbringen und das ist ja in
diesen Zeiten würde ich keine
Selbstverständlichkeit
irgendein Lager oder kann er sie
zusammenbringen und dann kommen wir
gleich auf Joe Biden zu sprechen weil
halt in keinem Lager ist so die Optik
war ja sehr herzlich zwischen beiden und
und Modi wie ist da das Verhältnis das
ist sicher gut ich glaube aber modisch
Strategie ist klar er will nicht in
einem Lager stehen er möchte genau diese
Position haben insofern war das alles
Wasser auf seine Mühlen der zu sein der
guckt mit wem geht was wo bin ich wie
kann ich das Ausloten wie kann ich die
miteinander verknüpfen und verbinden was
ihn natürlich auch geholfen hat glaube
ich tatsächlich ist das der Chinese
nicht da war das ist etwas was ihm
letzten Endes gefallen dürfte vorher hat
man gesagt dann ist es nicht nach vor
gegenüber Mutti ich glaube der war ganz
zufrieden damit also insofern hat er die
Bühne für sich hat sie gut genutzt und
ich glaube er hat auch Punkte gemacht
bei vielen anderen Teilnehmern und das
hat der Chinesin Abwesenheit nicht
machen können der Chinese war nicht da
spricht Chichi Ping du berichtest ja
sehr lange aus Amerika hat Joe Biden
diese Lücke
nutzen können hat er überzeugt oder hat
man doch auch ein bisschen gesehen dass
der Chinese im Hintergrund vielleicht
doch da war also ich habe vorhin noch
mal nachgeguckt als Joe Biden angetreten
ist 20021 hatten wir ja ein paar Gipfel
G7 und G20 und da ist er ja angetreten
und hat allen gesagt Amerika ist back
nachdem Trump jetzt weg war und alle
haben den Kopf geschüttelt und gefragt
ja wie lange denn eigentlich und er hat
allen damals gesagt Leute wir müssen den
Worten Taten folgen lassen weil nur dann
können wir beweisen dass die Demokratien
besser sind als die autoritären Regime
das sage ich jetzt vorweg weil der muss
jetzt das Gefühl haben dass die anderen
ist kapiert haben er selber fängt an zu
liefern noch mal der das Stichwort
dieser riesige Eisenbahn
Schiffsverkehr
Ölpipelines
Unterseekabel für Telekommunikation
zwischen Indien Nahost Nahost inklusive
Saudi Arabien und Europa ist ja Butter
bei die Fische übrigens gibt's einen
ähnlichen Deal in Sachen
Eisenbahnverkehr der auch hier
verhandelt wurde Simbabwe Angola auch
das sind ganz konkrete Dinge das heißt
er tut was dazu aber die anderen ziehen
mit das was er 2021 versprochen hat
bildbeck better world weil nur so kann
man im Grunde genommen die Demokratie am
Ende erhalten das scheint hier zu
resonieren deswegen fährt er
wahrscheinlich ziemlich zufrieden nach
Hause und Chichi steht an der Seite und
schaut zu für mich
Butter bei die Fische dann muss das
jetzt allerdings auch erst noch kommen
glaube ich absolut wir reden also die
Diplomaten feiern sich dafür dass sie
mir moranten unterschrieben haben das
ist aber natürlich bestenfalls das
unterste Level einer solchen
Entwicklungsgeschichte also da sind wir
noch ganz am Anfang und die gerade die
Schwellenländer die wollen das was
passiert oder absolut hier ist noch mal
ganz wichtig wir waren ja alle schon auf
vielen Gipfeln und jedes Mal kommt ein
Abschlusserklärung heraus wo wir das
Ende der am Ende das Gefühl haben das
ist jetzt ich erinnere mich 2019 mit
Trump ich glaube es war Osaka ein
13-seitiges Geschwurbel haben wir
übereinstimmend gesagt und da waren
Formulierungen mit so viel
relativierende Nebensätzen drin nur weil
man den kleinen genau am meisten
gemeinsamen Nenner finden musste dass am
Ende eigentlich nichts dabei rauskam der
war eigentlich gescheitert aber das
immer von dem Gipfel zu erwarten dass
hier 20 sitzen die konkrete Aktionen und
Maßnahmen beschließen die dann morgen
umgesetzt werden ist illusorisch die
sind dazu da dass das Framework den
Rahmen zu schaffen damit jeder einzelne
Staat etwas tut in Sachen Kampf gegen
den Klimawandel in Sachen
wirtschaftliche Perspektive für ihre
Menschen und da habe ich schon das
Gefühl wenn wir es nur nach der
Abschlusserklärung beurteilen können wir
sagen ist ein Misserfolg weil Ukraine
hätte viel stärker sein müssen aber ich
glaube entscheidend ist das was die hier
tatsächlich konkret beschlossen haben
die müssen jetzt auch machen diese
großen Infrastruktur Deals und ähnliches
ich würde gerne die Euphorie ein
bisschen Bremsen von Elmar und ist toll
dass du so viel Energie hast das weißt
habe ich nicht immer bei Joe Biden
gesehen ehrlich gesagt aber es sind
Riesensummen riesen Ankündigungen
gemacht worden du sagst zu Recht jetzt
muss was kommen und das ist strategisch
klar will man Anfüttern damit die nicht
ins Chinesische Lager gehen aber wenn
man auch den deutschen Bundeshaushalt
anguckt wenn man anguckt welche Zwänge
Olaf Scholz hat wo kommt denn auf einmal
diese ganzen Muskeln her die man hier
spielen lassen hat nee die Deutschen
haben ja nicht so ein riesiges
Infrastrukturprojekt angekündigt aber
und die deutschen versuchen uns auf eine
andere Art also Scholz hat's ja vor
allen Dingen diplomatisch versucht der
hat sich im Prinzip im letzten Jahr
total zum Anwalt gemacht des globalen
Südens wir erinnern uns wir waren
letztes Jahr die sieben Vorsitz als
Deutschland und ähm Scholz hatte ja nach
Ellmau zum deutschen die sieben Gipfel
Modi geholt er hat ähm Rama geholt er
hat mit Luna gesprochen er ist
rumgereist wie verrückt und ich glaube
jetzt sehen wir diese Ergebnisse auch
und auch die unterschiedlichen
Ergebnisse beim G7 Gipfel in Japan hat
man schon gesehen da war ja selensky als
Gast da das Modi auf serenski zugegangen
ist und ihm die Hand gegeben hat Lula
sollte sich mit selensky treffen dieses
Treffen kann aber nicht zustande danach
haben sie sich gegenseitig beschimpft
und ich finde das sehen wir jetzt auch
hier das sind jetzt die Ergebnisse das
sind auch die Ergebnisse von Scholz
seiner Arbeit das hat bei dem einen ganz
gut geklappt bei Mutti und es hat bei
dem anderen überhaupt nicht funktioniert
weil Lola was noch interessant wird weil
ja Luna im nächsten Jahr
G20 Vorsitz hat der Gipfel wird in
Brasilien sein und lola hat heute schon
gesagt auch wenn der Putin kommen will
der kann kommen den verhaften oder nicht
also umso wichtiger ist das was du sagst
was du sagst dass diese Mutter bei dir
Fische auch wirklich kommt und egal was
es kostet ja bevor wir noch mal auf
Putin auf die ganze Zentrale für Rolle
kommen und auf die Ukraine noch mal zu
diesen Ankündigungen wenn ich das ein
bisschen als europa-korrespondent sagen
darf gibt er dieses große Wort von
Global Gate das ist ja auch so ein
Initiative die gegen die chinesische
Seidenstraße gerichtetes 300 Milliarden
stehen da im Raum und wenn du mal genau
guckst ist das viel hot air viele viele
heiße Luft und ich frag mich so ein
bisschen ob das nicht über Tuschen soll
das eigentlich die westliche Welt in
vielen Punkten sehr zerstritten ist die
diejenigen die hier auf der Bühne stehen
sind alle irgendwo auf der politischen
Intensivstation oder auf dem emergency
room also wie stark ist wirklich der
Westen und wie substanziell sind diese
diese Versprechen das liegt in unserer
Hand also wenn die Europäer 300
Milliarden versprechen und fangen an nur
alte Projekte die vor zehn Jahren schon
angefangen haben da rein zurechnen dann
sind die anderen nicht doof die sehen
das die wissen dass sie wieder im Grunde
genommen ich will so ein scharfes Wort
nicht verwenden aber auf den Arm
genommen werden man könnte noch was
schärferes sagen ja
nur wenn Sie wirklich neue Projekte
anschieben durch die sich das Leben
Menschen selbst in einem Land wie
das vielleicht autoritäre Züge hat in
Ägypten oder eben das keine autoritären
Züge hat Senegal oder Ruanda in Afrika
oder andere Länder wenn sich das Leben
für die Menschen verbessert das ist das
was die Anführer dieser Staaten wollen
nur wenn wir das Liefern haben wir eine
Chance in dieser Auseinandersetzung mit
China und anderen weil sonst machen die
die Deals und deswegen noch mal am Ende
ist ja so wir gucken immer auf das
Papier und jeder einzelne Formulierung
ist uns wichtig aber mal ernsthaft wenn
jetzt drin gestanden hätte dass die G20
sich einigen das war eine russische
Aggression da in der Ukraine hätte das
irgendwas für die Ukraine verändert es
verändert sich doch für die Ukraine nur
etwas wenn Sie die Waffen geliefert
bekommen damit sie eben in der Lage sind
diesen Krieg am Ende für sich zu
entscheiden den schreckliche Vorstellung
was du sagst weil das heißt ja dass wir
im Prinzip uns in einen Wettlauf mit
China begeben um diese Länder zu kaufen
also es geht ja bei den Argumenten die
du bringst überhaupt nicht um Russland
oder die Ukraine es geht darum die
sollen was kriegen die wollen von uns
eine Brücke haben die wollen von unserem
Flughafen haben und eben nicht den
Vortrag ja aber es geht nicht darum wie
früher also die ich sag mal ehemaligen
Kolonialmächte oder die Reichen Europäer
geben Entwicklungshilfe und dann
versandet das nach ein paar Jahren
wieder so es geht um gemeinsame Projekte
auf Augenhöhe das du kannst das Normen
viel besser beurteilen ich meine china
ist in Länder hier in Asien reingegangen
Malaysia und andere hat nur große
Schulden hinterlassen und eisenbahndeals
die in die Hose gegangen sind wo heute
noch keine also machen
noch mal die Glaubwürdigkeit der
amerikanische Politik Ankündigung sie
sind bei der Welt wenn dir dir anguckst
sorry diesen jämmerlichen Abzug der
Amerikaner aus Afghanistan nach das
führt das sagt dort die Welt so bald die
irgendwie das Gefühl haben dass es gegen
amerikanischen Interessen spricht sind
die schneller weg als du gucken kannst
absolut die bauen aus einem
Trümmerhaufen den sie selber verursacht
haben gerade auf ob das klappt weiß
keiner aber nur mal ein Beispiel gestern
wurde hier auch beschlossen die Reform
von Weltbank und Währungsfonds neue
Milliarden Summen die zur Verfügung
gestellt werden müssen von den reichen
Ländern damit eben über die
Entwicklungsbanken solche Projekte
finanziert werden das ist was ganz
konkretes das ist hier noch nicht
tatsächlich umgesetzt aber wir werden im
November beim IBF und der
weltmarkttagung in Marrakesch werden wir
sehen ob quasi dieses Thematik sich
verändert und es einfacher wird dann
eben diese Gelder zu mobilisieren für
ein neues Netzwerk in Südafrika wo
beispielsweise gerade die komplette
Stromversorgung in Teilen zusammenbricht
also das sind konkrete Dinge und klar
wir können sagen die werden gekauft aber
am Ende ist es nicht weil man ein
Machthaber noch Geld in die
taschenschaufeln will Stichwort
Korruption sondern weil das Leben der
Menschen sich verbessert und daran
messen die Menschen ob wir es ernst
meinen weil sonst machen sie es mit den
Chinesen zusammen verspricht natürlich
original Ski genauso Jesus versprechen
und ihr müsst nicht mal unsere Werte
übernehmen ihr kriegt einfach nur unser
Geld und es muss sich lohnen deshalb an
die heißt begehrten Normen dein Land
Indien wie ist das ist das ist ja eine
Demokratie haben ihre unsere Werte
irgendeine Bedeutung oder geht es bei
Modi wirklich darum wer hilft mir am
schnellsten das Land reich zu machen
reich zu machen davon sind wir noch ein
Stück weiter entfernt es geht ja hier
viele viele das Wort mit dem das Kaufen
an die das ist mir auch viel zu hart
ehrlich gesagt weil wir das blendet mit
meiner Meinung nach aus welcher
Perspektive diese Länder kommen es gibt
da viel Nachholbedarf es gibt hier viel
Armut es gibt verständlicherweise viele
Projekte die herangezogen werden müssen
die vorangetrieben werden müssen um
diese Leute aus der Armut zu holen und
die Länder zu entwickeln das ist ein
Interesse was man nicht einfach so als
wir lassen uns kaufen ab tun kann
sondern das sind lebenswichtige Projekte
oftmals für diese Länder und deshalb ist
es wichtig dass die passieren und Modis
Interesse ist natürlich
wie alle anderen Anführer ihrer Länder
das auch sehen wir wollen das für unsere
Länder was passiert dass ich was
entwickelt wir brauchen dafür Hilfe ist
nicht es war jemand der sagt wir sind
sehr sehr stark aber es nicht blind er
ist auch nicht dumm und er weiß dass er
das alles nur mit Hilfe aus dem Ausland
erreichen kann insofern ist ihm das
alles sehr recht vielen Werte für ihn ja
aber natürlich sollten wir nicht unseren
Katalog jetzt gleich wieder anlegen er
ist natürlich jemals der auch sagt wir
haben unsere Wert wir haben unsere
Prinzipien das ist uns wichtig aber die
Ziele sind schon auch ganz klar Indien
nach vorn zu bringen
was ich die anderen Fragen wird wie
verlässlich sind die Partner die neuen
die wir haben oder die wir versuchen zu
bekommen ich würde gern noch mal ein
bisschen mehr über den Modi erfahren
weil du hast das letzte Mal zum Auto
gefahren sind durch den Verkehr das so
schön beschrieben was ist das ist das
ein Demokrat ist das ein Nationalist
oder was baut ihr auf und welche
Biografie hat er auch ist ja wenn du das
ihn mal ein bisschen beschreiben
könntest weil wir nicht auf die
Gelegenheit haben so intensiv auf diesen
faszinieren Mann zu gucken er ist
fasziniert er sich auch sehr erfolgreich
muss man sagen kommt aus kleinen
Verhältnissen hat sich hochgearbeitet
und das nötigt hier auch viel Respekt ab
also viele denken noch immer dass es
einer von uns der es geschafft hat er
den Weg gegangen ist vom kleinen
tv-verkäufer wo er auch mal ausgeholfen
hat in der Familie dann sich
hochgearbeitet hat studiert hat bis hin
zum Regierungschef und das sagen viele
ist doch etwas wo wir den Hut vorziehen
also der Mann hat Charisma der ist
rhetorisch sehr beschlagen er weiß wie
er die Leute ansprechen muss sie
mitnehmen muss was mir immer zu kurz
kommt wir reden dann oft darüber auch
bei früheren Besuchen des Bundeskanzlers
hier was in viele Chancen bietet es wird
selten geguckt was ist das für ein
Partner mit dem wir uns einlassen und da
muss man innenpolitisch schon mal sagen
das ist ein Nationalist das ist ein
eigentlich ein ultra-nationalist eine
religiöse Hardliner Hinduismus ist das
was für ihn zählt Minderheiten Muslime
auch Christen haben es zunehmend schwer
in diesem Land gibt viel Gewalt und das
ist nicht von ihm loszulösen und seiner
Partei hast bitte Stichwort gegeben
sieht der Bundeskanzler sieht die
Bundesregierung was das für ein Partner
ist oder ist man da ein bisschen naiv
also ich bin ja nicht die
Bundesregierung aber
natürlich wissen die was das für ein
Partner ist aber
was den Wert einer so einer sag mal was
im Wert so eine Erklärung betrifft ja
also wir reden jetzt davon
Butter bei die Fische und wir müssen da
ich will ob man das kaufen nennt oder
überzeugen nennt oder so ich finde schon
dass es ein Unterschied dass das auch so
eine Erklärung wichtig ist weil wir
sehen ja jetzt zum Beispiel gerade wie
Russland sich so langsam und zurückroppt
auf die auf die Weltbühne über solche
Erklärungen beim letzten Gipfel in Bali
ist noch eher abgereist heute bleibt er
bis zum Ende und steht da auch relativ
selbstverständlich rum beim nächsten Mal
ist dann vielleicht schon wieder Putin
dabei oder so
die Bundesregierung kennt das Dilemma
natürlich aber sie kann es nicht lösen
ja das ist
ein aber da an die ist dann nicht doch
das entscheidende nicht was hier in
irgendeiner Erklärung an drei Worten
drin steht sondern es entscheidend ist
ob die Bundesregierung Waffen liefert an
die Ukraine die dafür sorgen dass ein
Punkt erreicht wird in diesem Krieg das
Putin am Ende vielleicht doch verhandeln
muss und von dem maximalfordern abrückt
das ist doch eigentlich der Punkt das
ist der Punkt beim Thema Ukraine wo es
eine glaubwürdigkeitslücke gibt und das
ist auch der Grund ähm oder der Punkt
bei den anderen Themen die du
angesprochen hast wo du sagst
Verlässlichkeit können wir uns auf den
Westen denn überhaupt verlassen es
werden wirklich extrem viele Erklärungen
nach extrem vielen Gipfeln
unterschrieben aber zum Beispiel beim
Klimaschutz ist Deutschland in diesem
Jahr zum ersten Mal zum ersten Mal
erfüllt Deutschland die Verpflichtungen
die ist schon Verurteilten
unterschrieben hat ich will gar nicht
über zwei Prozent Ziel reden wo Scholz
in seiner Zeitenwende Rede gesagt hat
das wird ab sofort erfüllt wird jetzt
dieses Jahr wieder nicht erfüllt ist als
nächstes Jahr erfüllt werden aber
könnte man jetzt noch zig andere Sachen
nennen
ob das hier ein guter Gipfel und
schlechter war ich würde noch einmal auf
diese Wertedebatte kommen weil natürlich
jenseits der Waffenlieferung die die
Bundesregierung macht die in dir helfen
den Russen die Chinesen helfen den
Russen die ganze Welt hilft den Russen
wenn man es praktisch guckt Jenseits was
in diesen ähm in dieser Schlusserklärung
steht indem Sie Energie kaufen indem sie
sich Atomkraftwerke machen lassen also
am Ende ist es auch eine Frage wo steht
man
lavrov der hier war Scholz der ihm nicht
die Hand gibt ist das eigentlich auf die
Dauer zu vermeiden mit denen zu reden
oder sich zu zeigen über die ja der
Frieden geht ist das eine wirklich
schlaue Strategie dass du da auch nicht
also er hat jetzt auf diesem Gefühl
nicht die Hand gegeben aber wenn du
guckst ähm wie viele Politiker haben
darauf als Kriegsverbrecher und auch
Putin als Kriegsverbrecher bezeichnet
das hat Scholz nie getan also auf der
gefragt wurde als einmal ausgewichen
stolz telefoniert regelmäßig mit
verstehen er hatte auch vor jetzt gerade
mal wieder mit ihm zu sprechen da kam
dann der
pregorian-absturz-abschuss dazwischen
also das tut er nicht das tun andere und
die Frage ist ob das wirklich klug ist
aber Scholz hält sich da wirklich alle
Möglichkeiten offen wenn ich auch darf
die Amerikaner man hat ja das Gefühl die
Welt nicht am Abgrund aber es ist eine
sehr Krise der Welt und die Leute sind
nervös wo sind die die Lösung finden die
miteinander reden sind die Amerikaner an
den Russen dran sind sie an den Chinesen
dran oder ist man eigentlich noch in der
Position wo man sagt der Konflikt der
nutzt mir noch ich kann auch neue
Bündnisse schmieden und warte mal wie
die Sache sich sortiert also arbeiten
wir genug für den Frieden also ich kann
schwer beurteilen ob sonst Zynismus im
Weißen Haus gibt dass die sagen was den
noch mal weitergehen den Konflikt weiß
nutzt uns ja in der Auseinandersetzung
was natürlich neutral stimmt dass der
Ukraine kriegt der beste belegt für Joe
Biden war für seine dass wir uns in der
großen Auseinandersetzung zwischen
Demokratie und Autoritarismus befinden
trotzdem glaube ich am Ende eher denen
ist nicht daran gelegen den Konflikt
langfristig zu verlängern sondern denen
ist daran gelegen dass wir die Dinge die
alle bedrohen möglichst bald endlich mal
in den Griff bekommen und am liebsten
gemeinsam übrigens auch mit China
deswegen handelt man fröhlich weiter mit
China und redet ganz viel mit China
blinken war da Raimondo war Datei war da
und andere sind da gewesen obwohl man
sich über andere Sachen noch heftig
streitet redet man weiter gestern Abend
hat Joe Biden Mohammed bin Salman die
Hand gegeben und alle schreien gleich
boah und wie kann man nur das Mörder der
hat den und so weiter und das ist
richtig das ist er aber trotzdem ist es
für die Amerikaner auch wichtig gerade
mit Saudi-Arabien zu reden aus zwei
Gründen Saudi-Arabien soll sich
aussöhnen mit Israel was wäre das für
ein grandioser Erfolg wenn man das
vorantreiben kann eine Anerkennung und
eben die absinnung zwischen
Saudi-Arabien und Israel und parallel
Saudi-Arabien sollen mithelfen bei
diesen großen
Infrastrukturprojekten und sie da
gestern haben sie es gemacht sie saßen
mit am Tisch dabei also ich glaube wir
müssen verstehen
das große Fernziel zu erreichen geht
nicht mit einem Finger schnippen sondern
es geht nur Schritt für Schritt immer
mit den einzelnen Partnern reden nicht
nur multilateral sondern vor allen
Dingen bilateral ihnen Respekt zu zeigen
ihren Interessen auch ein Stück weit
entgegenzukommen und so Stück für Stück
im Grunde genommen voranzukommen und
Allianzen neue Bündnisse zu schaffen
oder alte Bündnisse auszudehnen um klar
zu machen es ist nicht mehr die Welt wie
namens Zweiten Weltkrieg wo wir einfach
entscheiden was passiert sondern wir
müssen gemeinsam entscheiden was
passieren sollen
verständlich
Saudi-Arabien ist ja auch extrem wichtig
für die den Versuch Frieden in der
Ukraine zu finden es gab zum ersten es
gab 30 Länder die sich in Kopenhagen
getroffen hat um über Frieden zu reden
der zweite Gipfel war dann schon 40
Länder der war ein Saudi-Arabien
enscheda und da waren die Chinesen dabei
zum ersten Mal und das hätte Deutschland
nie geschafft die Chinesen da hinzuholen
das hätten die Amis nie geschafft die
Chinesen da hinzu und das haben die
Saudis geschafft und dafür musst du eben
auch so eine blutige handschütteln wie
von MBS diesen Mohammed bin Salman in
diesem Kronprinzen und das hat Holz auch
getan er war ja da ja vielleicht noch
mal so eine
speed-antwort-nummer Geschichte auch
aufgrund auf der Zeit ähm die vielleicht
schwierig ist ist diese Erklärung zu
Ukraine ist das ein Erfolg oder dass das
kein Erfolg weil wenn man die Ukraine
anhört sind die tief verletzt die sagen
unsere Interessen sind hier zum Mantel
getragen worden man sieht uns nicht mehr
ist das falsch oder nicht falsch fange
ich mit dir an es ist ein Rückschritt in
Bali hatte sich die Weltgemeinschaft
noch also die 20 Staaten noch darauf
geeinigt russlandschaft zu verurteilen
minus minus minus Russland aber der
russland hat auch unterschrieben in Bali
aber man schrieb eben most Contis ja und
diesmal haben es alle unterschrieben
also auch Russland also russland hat
auch dieses Bekenntnis zur territorialen
Integrität mit unterschrieben was aus
russischer Sicht auch möglich ist weil
ja für die die Krim und so weiter genau
Russland ist also es ist kein Erfolg es
ist ein Rückschritt würde ich sagen aber
es ist besser als die Alternative und
das wäre scheitern
Mudi aus seiner Sicht ist das ein Erfolg
weil er diesen etwas schwächeren ja
absolut Kompromiss hingekriegt hat genau
weil er ein Kompromiss hat und das so
formulieren konnte dass es keinem so
unwahrscheinlich weh tun muss immer
wichtig dass die Unterschriften drunter
kommt und er hat die Sache so entschärft
dass das geht für mich zeigt das aber
auch noch mal und das darüber dürfen wir
uns nicht tauschen lassen die Ukraine
ist für Länder wie Indien und andere
hier nicht das große Thema wir sagen
immer das überschattet den ganzen Gipfel
in gewisser Weise tut es das vielleicht
aber das ist unsere Perspektive diese
Länder haben andere Themen und das war
den wichtigsten Ukraine auch gesperrt da
kommt die Verletzung es gibt nicht mal
die Videobotschaft das hat wenn ich es
richtig gelesen habe wo die abgelehnt
und das zeigt natürlich dass die gar
keine Bühne mehr haben zu bespielen und
trotzdem sind die Amerikaner stolz auf
diesen Kompromiss zurecht oder ist es
auch da ein bisschen Augenwischerei also
jeder der erwartet hat dass die die ist
dass der globale Süden im Grunde
genommen zustimmt einer noch viel
härteren Verurteilung oder so ist
einfach naiv weil schlich ergreifend die
die anderen Interessen haben was
passiert aber jetzt sie haben alle
unterschrieben territoriale Integrität
Souveränität das merken alle
allgemeinplätzchen sein weil es halt in
der Karte der Vereinten Nationen steht
aber da kann man sie alle beim porte
packen wenn es wieder zu entscheidenden
Verhandlungen oder auch Abstimmungen
kommt vielleicht sogar
Friedensverhandlungen irgendwann auch
die großen wie Indien Brasilien und
andere zur Amport DP fassen und sagt hey
meinen wir das ernst oder meinen wir das
nicht ernst sorry die unend-karte die
gibt's glaube ich Seiten nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg 45 da steht das
drinnen oder 48 da steht das drin und
ich habe ein ausrechnen lassen seitdem
haben wir vorsichtig geschätzt mehr als
200 Kriege gab absolut also insofern das
interessiert wirklich niemanden das
unterschreibt man und wenn es ein stört
hat selbst die Amerikaner nicht
interessiert ich glaube also ich
verstehe nicht ganz die Euphorie ja weil
wenn wir im Grunde genommen diese Dinge
aufgeben am Ende genau diese Punkte dann
haben wir die Weltordnung von nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg erledigt und dann
sieht die neue Weltordnung so aus wie
China sich das vorstellt dass sich jeder
nehmen kann was er will jetzt kann man
sagen die Amerikaner haben sich nicht
dran gehalten ja absolut die haben
Kriege geführt in Afghanistan in Irak
und anderswo haben sie nicht dran
gehalten die Frage ist gibt es genug
Vertrauen das langsam im Entstehen ist
dass die die jetzt am Ruder sind wir
wissen nicht wer die nächste
Präsidentschaftswahl dass die die jetzt
am Ruder sind ist vielleicht ernster
meint und übrigens auch die Europäer man
meinen die Europäer es ernster mit all
diesen Dingen als jetzt in der
Vergangenheit gedacht ich will noch zu
einem anderen wichtigen Thema kommen wo
man ja auch schon ganz viel
unterschrieben hat Klima und Klimaschutz
man hat das Gefühl wenn man Indien und
China sagen was er da schreibt Europäer
eure Standards das könnte ja gerne
machen wir haben unser eigenes Tempo und
dazu gehört Kohle Kohle also wie ist
dieser Gipfel hinsichtlich der
Klimafrage zu bewerten fange ich mit dir
an Norbert oh Gott
ja ich katastrophal würde ich fast sagen
das ist wirklich katastrophal dass man
sich da so wenig bewegt aber die Bremser
sind zu stark und einer der zentralen
Bremser das hast du gesagt äh ist der
Gastgeber und der hat so ein Einfluss
auf die Verhandlungen gehabt die wie wir
hören so intensiv wie noch nie waren die
seit dem letzten Gipfel auf Bali
sozusagen mit Volldampf losgegangen sind
das ganze Jahr über durch verhandelt
worden und immer wieder ging es
natürlich auch um diese zentralen Fragen
und immer wieder hat Indien aber auch
klar gemacht es gibt einen Punkt über
die Kohle da kommen wir nicht zusammen
und das ist schon tragisch für die große
Klima Problematik also das ist sehr
untergegangen
zu Hause verkaufen das ist ja schwierig
weil er sowieso eine Klima Diskussion
hat wenn er sagen muss also wir machen
weiter und die anderen die ja viel
wichtiger fast noch sind beim
Klimaschutz sagen wir aber nicht naja
wir haben es ja gehört jetzt in seinen
Statements er sucht sich aus der
gipfelerklärung die Punkte raus die
tatsächlich irgendwie positiv klingen
und wo tatsächlich auch was
festgeschrieben wurde aber Fakt ist ja
dass die zwei bevölkerungsreichsten
Länder dieser Erde im Prinzip nicht mehr
bereit sind richtig mitzuziehen und das
ist eine richtig schlechte Nachricht
hier ist neugierigen aber nochmal nicht
neu so war es in den letzten Jahren
aufgeschrieben weil das wichtig ist 2019
haben die damals beim G20-Gipfel
beschlossen die Unterzeichner der Paris
Vereinbarung die in Buenos Aires deren
Unumkehrbarkeit bestätigt haben und zu
ihrer Umsetzung entschlossen sind
bestätige noch einmal ihre Zusage der
vollständigen Umsetzung wobei sie die
gemeinsamen aber unterschiedlichen
Verantwortlichkeiten und jeweiligen
Fähigkeiten berücksichtigen im Lichte
unterschiedlicher nationaler Umstände
dieser schwobesatz über 40 Worte
gilt heute genauso nämlich das alles was
in der Frage sich bewegen kann
eigentlich immer auch mit den nationalen
Umständen verknüpft ist
und jetzt müssen wir mal in die
Abschlusserklärung von gestern gucken
und da steht im Grunde genommen an
einigen Stellen drin dass die Strukturen
geschaffen werden um den Ländern die
nationale Umstände haben die es ihnen
nicht ermöglichen auf erneuerbare
Energien so einfach umzusteigen das
künftig zu ermöglichen durch riesige
Infrastrukturprojekte durch
Unterstützung von Wind und Sonnenenergie
in Afrika und anderswo will sagen wer
erwartet dass hier beschlossen wird wir
senken dass alles da und da der hat am
Ende nur irgendeine Absichtserklärung
wäre aber erwartet dass die
Rahmenbedingungen geschaffen werden
damit sie diese Ziele von Paris da
stehen sie ja drin Erreichen der kommt
wirklich ein ganzes Stück voran und da
würde ich mal sagen ist die
Abschlusserklärung von gestern so
schlecht nicht ich brauche noch mal
letzte Frage von euch auch Thema
Optimismus
wir sind vier
ältere Herren aber wenn ich mir aber
wenn ich mir angucke werde auf der Bühne
steht und über das Schicksal der
Menschheit ähm brät und auch über die
Zukunft der Zeit obwohl er selber gar
nicht mehr so zu viel Zukunft vor sich
hat da bist du ja mit 70 fast noch in
Jungspund und der und der Scholz ist ein
Teenager wie kommt es dass diese Welt
von alten Männern immer noch regiert
wird das weiß ich nicht also ich wüsste
es gern aber es ist wirklich dramatisch
dass ein Volk wie die USA ja mit so
vielen Talent mit so viel Millionen
Einwohnern vor dieser entscheidenden
Wahl wo es darum geht Trump oder beiden
und das da geht es ja noch um viel mehr
keinen anderen Kandidaten aufbieten kann
als diesen Mann wo man immer mitleidet
wenn er die Gänge runter geht oder wenn
auf dem roten Teppich kommt deshalb bloß
nicht stolpert oder irgendwas ist das
politische Themen Indien auf Seniorität
ausgerichtet bis man hochkommt ja ein
Stück weit schon glaube ich die haben
auch unheimlich viele junge aufstehende
Talente und auch die setzen sich nicht
durch einen entscheidenden Stellen das
braucht eine Weile und Modi hat auch
diesen Status erreicht ne er ist auch
dieser etwas der sich als über Vater
inszeniert auch ein bisschen und die
Leute zu schauen auf letztes Abteile
Optimismus über 80 und trotzdem fit für
alles und man würde sich wünschen als
Deutscher ach könnte der nicht als
Vermächtnis dass ich jetzt an den
jüngeren oder eine jüngere noch besser
abgeben und sich zurückziehen aber das
ist naiv warum weil schlicht und
ergreifend einem Land das so polarisiert
ist die Leute am Ende jemanden brauchen
hinter dem sie sich versammeln der die
auktoritas im altrömischen
Stil im Grunde mitbringt das heißt einer
der gezeigt hat durch Handeln dass man
Dinge von ihm erwarten kann der auch
bereit ist Kompromisse zu schließen
jetzt kann man lange darüber streiten ob
beiden das gut oder schlecht macht ist
es völlig Wurst aber es ist niemand da
der im Grunde genommen diese oktoberitas
mitbringt und das macht so schwer ich
glaube aber wir reden für die nächste
Wahl in vier Jahren über den großen
Generationswechsel ich glaube übrigens
auch in Europa und auch in anderen
Ländern dieser Welt
ja Thema Generationswechsel mal sehen
was mit uns passiert das jedenfalls war
das war das gipfelgespräch dass wir
geführt haben vielen Dank fürs zuschauen
und zuhören ich hoffe es hat ihnen
gefallen und ja wir freuen uns auf Ihre
Kommentare und bleiben Sie gesund und
fit danke